welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david today you can
follow me on twitter at fair and balance
find me on facebook facebook.com
fair and balanced youtube
youtube.comfire and my other youtube
channel youtube.com
fair and balanced
let's get back into more of
some of the news here and i think one of
the biggest non-stories
of the last week
was mike lindell's cyber symposium that
as we all know came to a close at the
end of last week
august 13th came and went and in case
you haven't noticed donald trump is
still
not the president of the united states
nor
did we see president biden and vice
president harris resign
as lindell had also predicted at one
point
now
to his credit sure he had pushed back
the date of donald trump's reinstatement
he said well it's not going to happen
august 13th maybe september now he says
maybe later down the road but now it's
really looking
like it's not going to happen as if it
was ever going to happen
here's the thing
the cyber symposium was an absolute crap
show
and that is about putting it as nicely
as humanly possible
the guy got up there on stage kicked the
whole thing off with steve bannon who by
the way later in the week
came out and actually criticized lindell
for not providing any evidence at all
like the packet captures where the hell
were the packet captures
because they were nowhere to be seen
and of course the rest of the symposium
was nothing more than just powerpoints
that people had put together
with numbers that they didn't source
from anywhere they just said well here's
what it was but here's what we think it
really was
and they provided no evidence at all
to back up their little phony numbers
that they threw up on the screens
so you know there was that then of
course we had mike lindell's own cyber
security expert gave an interview to the
washington times where he said yeah
there was no evidence of any hack at all
so we could not sign off on lindel's
claims that there was a hack
lindell insisted there was anyway and in
fact actually when the gateway pundit
reported on the washington times
interview with that uh cyber security
expert lindell got up on stage
and he said well obviously the gateway
pundit person
is a cia plant
then of course you had his claim that he
was assaulted in his hotel room
or not his hotel room in his hotel lobby
and no record of this he showed up the
next day not a scratch on him
you know no police report filed so as
far as we know there was no actual
assault that took place and then on
friday at the end of all of this lindell
comes out gives an interview
basically tried to explain away why the
whole thing was an abject failure by
saying
it's because antifa infiltrated the
cyber symposium
that was that was his excuse
antifa infiltrated the cyber symposium
they went in there he said they changed
the name tags
and and then they
disrupted that also didn't happen by the
way i feel the need to point that out
that didn't happen but but here's the
thing he didn't say what they did after
they changed the name tags
so like did they change the name tags
and just go sit in the crowd and watch
because if so i i don't think that's
throwing the whole thing off i think
that's just
whatever
the point is there was never any
evidence
and that's why that cyber symposium was
a completely fact free event
the only part of it that was even mildly
entertaining was when he found out his
lawsuit
defamation lawsuit against him was going
to move forward and he bolted off stage
came back did a seven minute rant
against dominion voting systems
and again in an interview after the
thing ended he said oh well we're gonna
we're gonna have it all oh he had alan
dershowitz
joined via zoom i believe and dershowitz
said oh yeah in the in the lawsuit the
discovery all this will come out bring
it
dominion is clearly not afraid
dominion as far as we know has
absolutely nothing to hide but what we
do know
is that all the ridiculous claims that
mike lindell made on stage will be used
against him in a court of law
because he won't stop the defamation
so yeah he's in trouble
he's in a lot of trouble with his
followers because he didn't give them
any information again even bannon the
guy who has platformed mike lindell for
months and months to to spread these
lies
called him out for not producing any
evidence
the packet captures that lindell been
talking about for months were nowhere to
be seen
and he also really destroyed any legal
defense he may have of course in that
defamation case
so rather than ending with a bang
rather than ending with the
reinstatement of former president donald
trump
mike lindell's cyber symposium ended
with a whimper
a whimper that is really going to make
it hard for him to defend himself in
this dominion defamation lawsuit
if you're a guy the place you want to go
for better skin is geology one of our
sponsors geology has skin care routines
for men that actually work personalized
for you by a dermatologist whether it's
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin or you
want to protect your skin geology can
help you take their quiz a dermatologist
matches you with a unique skin regimen
designed for your specific needs you'll
get a 30-day trial with the treatment
they recommend if you like it they'll
keep sending it to you it's not a magic
cream or bogus miracle whatever these
are just clinically evidence-based
products used by dermatologists tailored
to you
by a dermatologist you're only getting a
treatment that you actually need
i took the quiz the dermatologist
matched me with a treatment it's working
great i love how my skin is looking you
really can see the difference go and
take geology's free quiz
and when you use my link right
underneath this video you'll save up to
40 percent on your first month